royal watchers believe Britain's Queen
Elizabeth will never retire but we
learned this morning her husband will
Buckingham Palace says Prince Phillip
will give up his royal duties later this
year his 96th birthday is next month
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the palace
where rumors were flying overnight after
a surprise gathering of the Queen's
staff Jonathan good morning good morning
this all hands on deck staff meeting
took place inside the palace
earlier this morning people were brought
in on short notice from all over the
country raising at one point concern
about the health of the Queen of course
all of that attention pivoting to the
prince who announced that upcoming
retirement the Duke of Edinburgh was
Dean just yesterday at a sports ceremony
in London we now know it's one of his
last engagements he'll make as Prince in
a statement Buckingham Palace said His
Royal Highness has decided that he will
no longer carry out public engagements
from the autumn of this year I think
it's a decision that he has taken with
the Queen but he feels at the age of 95
he is perhaps not quite as sharp as he
was and I think people we just doesn't
want to feel that pressure over time the
91 year old Queen Elizabeth however will
carry on her full schedule as normal
Philip has been a steadfast companion of
Her Majesty for more than 70 years the
two met when they were just children as
Prince he provides her support and from
time to time controversy he has a
reputation of occasional political
incorrectness he may be the oldest
member of the royal family but he's
still involved in more than 700
organizations this retirement from
public life follows a lifetime of
devotion to the monarchy
and the Pala says the prince is in good
health at this point is unclear where
he's going to spend his retirement but
Gayle he's got several castles in a very
big palace to choose from
Jonathan very good point he's got lots
of options thank you very much he looks
great lots lots